[Applaudissements]
le champion de l'an passé
attention à partout chez vous un 10/10
retourne c'est parti entre trois noms
caip skype et ebay
alors black eyed peas c'est rsa
ah oui le beau gala dont blague a pris
les fiches voilà le savon black eyed
peas ce qu'il fallait démontrer si tu es
2.0 l'attention et ne pouvait pas perdre
sur les rappeurs aspap non non non vas-y
on se réveille chez vox et redescend
très costaud dis tout de suite je vais
pas la fin de l'émission je m'en vais je
vous jure que c'est un super job tu veux
que toute la france non non non si vous
perdez je prends mes affaires et je
quitte l'année une reprise au sort je
suis jeune et jolie et c'est jean luc
qui fera la fin de l'émission n'ont
gagné
attention il ya deux fois pour pf et
laurent de tumaco des retours attention
ici s'il a bien mis 6 et 6 blocs l'ami 6
[Musique]
de partout vous jouez également de chez
vous ainsi m6 se lâche
les prochains le prochain rapport à
trouver c'est parti on y va vite des
boules qui bouge
[Musique]
je ne sais pas pourquoi l'état viendra
doubler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention en 3 le prochain les parties
alors téléspectateurs pour les
téléspectateurs attention à l'ordre ont
peu d'intérêt ni way qui est levé d'âge
nikhil attention je vous l'a dit au met
la dernière main et la dernière grille
sont assez bons et non non non ils n'ont
pas gagné parce que je fais nouvelles
règles mais tient à cette réponse compte
pour 150 points pour l'instant il l'a
tuée sur les à deux ça peut toujours y
avoir 150 2 à 4 en fait je vais en fait
foi tu ne vas travailler pas du tout le
chantier rendez vous attention ça se
joue sous la pression 3 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à toi
l'escale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah bon merci salut les gars merci les
gars merci merci je n'ai pas
professionnel
tiens jean-luc va pas je vous racontais
les places en haut de ma personne je
n'ai pas écouté de shanghai ocs mais il
n'y a pas de prompteur allez on aime
tenez voilà je vais vous proposer un
petit rire même profil que je peux
[Applaudissements]
l'émission touche à sa fin encore une
petite surprise puisque nous avons la
chance l'immense bonheur d'avoir ce soir
alonso et soprano
[Musique]
nous sommes chez nous
[Applaudissements]
amy sas ont fait la force et dans
l'intuition le rappeur
mixé par respect qu'ils ont fait tout ça
bien sûr c'était grâce à un tri mais
bien sûr merci pour les cheveux longs
non mais écoutez un petit buzz quelque
chose comme ça là aux dés